[Music]
firebase c
is the map that really lets us explore
the character of samantha maxis to an
extent that we never
ever have before d machina was really
introducing
people to the darkheather storyline
which you know as i've said in the past
only exists because of everything that
had gone before but it now has
a whole new trajectory and firebase c is
the one that really
makes it explode what i love about
firebase c is that it's set in vietnam
in this all new experience we've broken
the map up into two locations
the firebase which is the facility where
scientists and
soldiers do experiments and mine the
dark ether
and then we have the village that's
where the scientists sleep and
do all their research my teams reach the
village
the way you play in d machina might not
necessarily translate over to firebase c
the low and level design of outpost 25
calls back a little bit to moon
in that you start in the village and
then take a teleporter over to
the outpost itself once you're at the
outpost there's a bit of a
central area a hub if you will that
players can
choose what path they want to go to they
can run around the outside of the
map itself and the outer edge
you know working on a zombies map is a
very interesting experience
i've been working on zombies maps since
call of duty world of war
a lot of the way we do the sound design
for these maps is still kind of rooted
in how we did it back then it's very
sea to your pants wild and crazy let's
try and make this stuff sound really
cool
scary creepy nothing's off the table
when it comes to zombie sound design
because of the world that they inhabit
so outpost 25 is an omega outpost and
they're doing a lot of
science experiments there's a lot of
different little things mechanics that
you can interact with
it'll be up to players to kind of
discover how they work and how to make
use of them
i'm most excited for players to
experience these assault rounds it's a
very different
way of playing than you used to fall is
more of like the hold out style of
gameplay but
it's not so static you still have to
move around
artillery strike and napalm strike start
to become
key at the higher rounds especially in
the assault rounds because it's just
excellent crowd control on top of just
being super epic
standing at an elevated position kind of
looking down at the defense lines while
these artillery strikes are just
just bombarding the play space it's it's
awesome
when we got together to try to
brainstorm ideas for
new enemies you know there's lots of
different ideas that came about
the other one we kind of gravitated
towards was was this idea of
the ambush style enemy now the mimic is
tricky sky hides out as items and
as you approach them transforms into
this tentacled beast that grabs you
you suck you in bites you basically if
you
see something sitting around and wonder
why nobody picked it up
why is that awesome item still sitting
there it's probably a minute
the rai k 84 or as we like to call it
the ray k uh is based on an old russian
prototype runner weapon that never saw
the light of day
it's built using parts from an ak-74
married with experimental technology
max's contact will help us infiltrate
it off are you there finally
there is little time to waste when we
started this dark ether story it was
it was kind of daunting in some ways
because you know a lot of us have been
working on zombies since the beginning
and that's where the excitement
particularly with this
fresh start and the dark ether story has
been
kind of reinvigorating for the team i
don't think i've ever felt as excited
about post-launch seasons of content as
i do this year
i think people are probably when they
get to the end of this they're going to
look back at what we've done and go
i did not see that coming if
any harm comes to her i will kill you
myself
you